Does "Fast X" mark a return
to form for the "Fast" saga,
or is it way too over-the-top? Early reviews
are in, so gather your found family and
check out what the critics are saying as
the end of the road officially begins.
The “Fast & Furious” franchise has evolved
from a slightly over-the-top series about
street racing and organized crime to
a spectacle of vehicular destruction,
skyscraper stunts, and even a trip to outer
space in a rocket-powered Pontiac Fiero. Dom
Toretto stomped so hard he brought down
a crumbling parking garage, Luke Hobbs
redirected an ice-skating torpedo with his arms
— the action is absurd, and that’s the appeal.
"That was awesome!"
Of course, this legacy of uninhibited
ridiculousness means that "Fast X" has
some almighty expectations to
live up to. The good news, though,
is that the franchise hasn't run out of
gas in the action department just yet.
Early reports indicate that the
latest sequel is non-stop carnage,
with critic and podcast host
Nathan Flynn posting on Twitter,
"FAST X is a fun time at the movies delivering
all the high-octane action global spectacle,
and grumbled Vin Diesel monologues about
family you come to expect from this franchise."
That said, bonkers action is meaningless unless
there's a central conflict between Dom's ragtag
group of heroes and a formidable villain. Jason
Momoa's Dante has been tasked with bringing the
inferno in "Fast X," and early reactions have
heaped praise on the actor's performance.
"I'm Dante. Enchanté."
Momoa reportedly relishes his
villainous role in "Fast X."
The actor believes that he got stuck playing
goody-two-shoes characters for far too long,
so he told Variety that he welcomes the
opportunity to portray a compelling bad
guy in a high-profile project.
His passion shows on the screen,
and fans have praised Dante’s wickedness on social
media. Critic and podcaster Matt Rorabeck tweeted,
"Jason Momoa is the exact amount of
unhinged needed in the latest chapter
of this live-action Saturday morning cartoon
soap opera. I live, laugh, love the melodrama."
Some viewers think Momoa is
the highlight of the entire
movie. Critic and journalist Scott Menzel wrote,
"Jason Momoa steals the show over and over again."
Writer and critic Kit Stone added,
"Fast X is the best ride you'll take this year.
Jason Momoa's peacockish
villainy steals the show."
Don't expect Dante to be a sympathetic
villain, either. Several early viewers
compared the character to the Joker
due to his unhinged personality,
such as Cinemablend's Eric Eisenberg, who posted,
"[Momoa's Dante is] a gleeful
psychopath, and it's delightful."
Glowing early reviews aside, the "Fast & Furious"
franchise isn't for everyone. Some people can't
look past the unrealistic action setpieces, so
"Fast X" probably won't be met with universal
acclaim. Film critic Emmanuel Noisette found some
scenes too over-the-top to comprehend, writing,
"[Fast X] is on cruise control with
ridiculous stunts and logic-defying action."
However, the reviewer did at least reserve
some praise for Momoa's villainous performance,
noting that the actor, quote, "was the
saving grace as an entertaining villain."
On the flip side, some viewers had a blast
with the gung-ho action sequences. "615
Film" critic Kevin Allen believes that "Fast
X" is the best franchise installment since
"Furious 7," simply due to the absurdity of the
action scenes and the performances of Momoa and
Brie Larson. Additionally, the reviewer
took a moment to praise the filmmakers,
saying that director Louis Letterier
"maximizes the stakes with solid direction."
Elsewhere, some early viewers appreciated the
self-aware nature of the film and praised
it for not taking itself too seriously,
meaning that it's everything people expect
at this point from a "Fast & Furious" yarn.